comme c'est jour d'ouverture en plus
profiter du beau temps profiter des
arbres un jour ensoleillé pour les
premiers visiteurs de l'arboretum du
muséum d'histoire naturelle après
presque cinq mois de fermeture
une balade au milieu des arbres à la
découverte d'espèces du monde entier on
n'a pas de jardin du coup voilà on s'est
dit on va faire une belle balade des le
marché à pied ça peut être un sportif
qui simplement un endroit tranquille et
naturel ça peut être les gens qui
viennent découvrir les la biodiversité
la faune la flore simplement dans un
espace très paisible où il ya vraiment
de l'espace pour le visiteur on n'est
pas trop serré et puis ça peut être les
jardiniers ou les botanistes qui sont un
peu plus spécialisés qui viennent voir
des collections particulières star de
cette réouverture le sakura autrement
connu sous le nom de cerisiers japonais
plus remarquables à voir maintenant
c'est sûr la cerise le japonais condé
floraison vraiment très éclatante alors
c'est au début
bientôt il y aura d'autres variétés qui
vont s'ouvrir actuellement il ya des
variétés à fleurs roses vifs mais on a
des fleurs de toutes les couleurs du
blanc aux roses
les 2500 espèces végétales de
l'arboretum n'attire pas que les
promeneurs des visiteurs plus atypiques
profite également de l'espace quelques
chevreuils qui nous ont coupé la route
et qui se sont arrêtés en dressant leurs
oreilles donc il ya beaucoup d'oiseaux
de mammifères donc on a des chevreuils
des renards on a beaucoup d'oiseaux
comme des faisant des ronds la tat
d'espèces et puis aussi des insectes qui
viennent à butiner les prairies fleuries
qui sont totalement sauvage elle aussi
l'entrée est payante ou sous forme
d'abonnement annuel
plusieurs parcours sont prévus ainsi
qu'une randonnée de 10 km avec comme
point d'orgue la longue allée des cèdres
bleus à deux pas du château de
versailles